elden ring is a difficult game not only
in challenging combat but also in
cryptic and unclear instructions and
explanations and despite it being more
straightforward than his predecessors it
can still leave many things unclear the
difficulty of the gameplay the unsurety
of how certain mechanics work and the
high chance that a player might not even
notice they are missing some vital
aspect or mechanic can make things more
frustrating than they need be so this is
a short guide on how to get a good grasp
of the early game of eldon rank this
won't be an exhaustive list of
everything you can or should do but it
will be a straightforward guide about
how to get a based weapon learn some
mechanics and find some core items that
will put you in a good place to explore
the lands between without wanting to die
at least not as much
so the first fight is expected death and
the tutorial is straightforward so we're
ignoring them once we get into the world
step one is going to be getting our
weapon a curved greatsword called the
bloodhound fang it requires some
strength and dexterity stats to properly
wield so choose a starting class like
the samurai or warrior first location is
the church of ella which is about as
obvious as can be head there light the
bonfire and say hi to the smithing table
where you'll upgrade your weapon and
kill the merchant and don't leave the
church without touching the grace to
activate it races are your checkpoints
and fast travel locations so you always
want to activate them all the swirling
light around them makes them hard to
miss so be on the lookout for that as
you explore the world next we want our
steed torrent because foot travel is
slow you receive torrent after resting
at the gate front grace which is up the
road and to the left on the map head
there feel free to kill the mobs on the
way if you want souls you can sneak
attack them by crouching up to their
backs but they're not too hard either
way activate and rest at the grace and
melina will visit melina is the one who
lets you level up at grace sites she'll
give you a whistle to call torrent pop
that in your pouch and you're ready to
ride
now we'll be following the road east on
the way through the ruins pick up the
map on the pillar these unlock more
detail on your map screen and they show
up on the basic brown maps as small
pillars they're usually on or next to
main roads but they can be surprisingly
easy to miss especially if you're
wandering around on the sides there's
another grace on the other side of the
ruins and then we can head off when the
road forks go left and you'll soon find
a grace to the right
[Music]
activate and head southeast into the
forest there will be another pillar on
your map and you can find the east limb
grave map item
[Music]
there's also a minor urge tree nearby
which is basically just a really big
tree so it should be easy to find and
you can pick up some nice loot from that
too southwest from the tree and south
south east from the grace you'll find
mistwood ruins which has a big bear and
a big wolf you can hear the wolf howl on
the north side of the ruins
[Music]
once you hear the howling open up the
map and fast travel back to the church
of ella the place with the merchant and
the smithing table if it's nighttime you
might meet the witch rena she'll give
you items for summoning spirit ashes but
if she doesn't show up don't fret you
can buy the same items from another
merchant speak to kalei and ask him
about the halloween he'll tell you about
it and give you the snap gesture with
that head back to the ruins and snap why
the berserk reference will jump down and
you can speak to him again on the north
side of the ruins he's hunting for a man
named derewill that's who we're going to
get our weapon from the name's blythe
he fled somewhere nearby after speaking
to wolfman get back on the road and head
south
just below the fork will be a somber
smithing stone which we'll use to
upgrade our weapon
keep heading south until you find the
agil lake south brace just south of that
is an ever jail a zone that holds a boss
fight in it you'll find these fights
scattered throughout the game enter the
ever jail and summon bly you don't have
to but if you're trying to fight a boss
solo without leveling up this guide is
probably wasted on you the fight
shouldn't be too hard with blythe if you
let him take the aggro just watch out
for the quick dash attacks
emerge from the everglade victorious
with your new sword and you'll find
blythe present to give you a reward
another somber smithing stone chances
are you won't have stats to wield the
bloodhound fang immediately so put some
of the runes you got into dexterity if
you two hand the sword you won't need to
have the full strength requirement level
2 strength works just fine now we'll
head back once more to the church of
ella we want to upgrade the sword at the
smithing table but you might not have
enough rooms the ruins are a decent farm
and there's a valuable item down the set
of stairs or if you continue up the road
to the west you'll find good enemies to
farm too along the road you'll find a
golden seed to upgrade your healing
flask
and a little red riding hood who gives
an ashen spirit
keep going up and you'll find a grace in
a tunnel that sets you up for your first
boss fight feel free to turn around and
farm the enemies in the zone behind once
you've gotten around 1500 extra souls
you can upgrade your sword to plus two
and it will be hitting decently hard
especially with the art of war left
trigger slash at this point you can go
fight the first real boss spoiler alert
on the name margaret the fel omen you'll
probably die a good bit but you'll do
decent damage and molina will visit
again to tell you you're actually based
and take you to visit the round table
hold a key sanctuary and where you can
find a merchant selling the ashen spirit
bell in the left wing there's also a
blacksmith here too though if you want
some more wiggle room to die less in the
boss fight there are some flash upgrades
we can get head back to the agile lake
south grace and ride further south
there's another grace past the bridge
and then we're going to want to follow
the road west until we get to the
northwest tip of the peninsula head into
the church of pilgrimage and find a
sacred tier which will increase the
amount you're healed by your flask and
then keep heading south along the
coastline till you come to the fourth
church of america and find another
sacred tier
lastly we want the flask of wondrous
physics which you might have picked up
if you explored north of the wolf boy if
not head back to the north east grace
miss wood outskirts and ride up the road
until you reach the third church of
america here is another sacred tier and
a new flask that of wondrous physic this
is a new consumable that will recharge
at graces you get one sip and you can
mix different effects at graces
depending on which crystal tears you
have which is a key item crystal tears
are what we found at the minor herb tree
earlier and more can be found around
analogous trees throughout the game
though they might be a little bit harder
to acquire if you haven't upgrade your
crimson flask at the grace both charges
and healing potential in addition to
mixing your flask of wondrous physics
which you should throw in an equipment
slot
now you have a strong weapon which will
scale well into the mid and late game
with more upgrades along with some buff
flasks and maybe even an ashen spirit or
two you are well equipped and on decent
footing for the market fight you can of
course level up your characters more but
this footage of me beating market is a
samurai class that has only been leveled
up twice both going into deck's points
the weapon art slash is very strong not
only are you equipped for margat in our
journey here which is pretty easily done
within an hour of gameplay we've come
across a number of eldon rings important
mechanics weapon upgrades ever jails npc
quest lines and summoning flask upgrades
minor herd trees and map expansions to
name just a few there are plenty more
mechanics in elton ring and you'll come
across many but not all of them in your
first playthrough but now you are
prepared to a good degree you do decent
damage and can have a bit of flexibility
in assigning your future skill points
and you have an understanding of some of
the more vital game mechanics like
flasks and weapon upgrading now all
that's left to do is go explore die and
be merry in the lands between
for a final extra tidbit of loot for
those of you still watching it's
unnecessary but it's pretty strong you
can find an urge tree on the southern
peninsula it's going to be to the east
of the fourth church of america at this
earth tree you're going to find an erd
tree avatar which is a boss that you're
going to have to fight these avatars are
found at many of the minor herb trees
around the world of the lands between
but this avatar isn't too strong and
it's a good way to learn some of the
horseback mechanics and combat if you
defeat it you'll be rewarded with
another crystal tier this one negates
some degree of physical damage by giving
you a bubble shield it basically gives
you a free hit where you won't take much
damage
and that's all i have for a beginner's
guide to the early game of eldon ring
hope you'd enjoy the video and if you
want to see more elden ring content both
in guides and lore be sure to stick
around my channel
[Music]
you